hey everyone lucy here in this video i
wanted to talk about how i passed the
aws certified cloud practitioner exam in
three weeks
before we get started as an introduction
i'm a current university student in
sydney australia
and i interned at aws so the reason i
decided to make this video is because i
wanted to share my personal experience
with how i prepared for the exam
what resources i used and what i wish i
did differently so that you don't have
to jump from website to website trying
to figure out how to start your own card
learning journey
overall the exam is 90 minutes long with
65 multiple choice questions covering a
few main domains
and you can choose to take it either at
home or at a local testing center
a question i get asked a lot by people
is how much previous experience or
knowledge do i need to have if i want to
take this exam
as you can see here aws recommends
having at least six months of experience
with the aws cloud in any role
and a basic understanding of it services
with that being said though you don't
necessarily have to have an i.t
background or any experience with aws
don't let that stop you from preparing
for the exam
the aws cloud practitioner exam is
foundational level
and there are so many online courses out
there that start from the very basics
the only thing you need to keep in mind
though is that it may take a few more
hours to understand more complex
concepts if you haven't come across
something similar before
it took me around 15 hours of study to
gain the confidence to sit the exam
and here's how my time was broken down
first i set up an aws account and played
around with the aws console
this is a very important first step
because even though you can probably get
away with not having any hands-on
experience with using aws before sending
the exam
it's really important that you interact
and apply the concepts you learn
and see how they're actually used the
good thing is that most of these
services that i use were either free or
had a free tier
so i didn't have to pay any additional
charges during my learning experience
so go ahead and try launching and
terminating easy2 instances
uploading a photo of your pet onto s3
and creating your own vpc
the second thing that i did was go
through lectures on a udemy course
i really recommend looking into this
particular course taught by an
instructor called stefan
there was around 11 hours of video
content and this was where i spent most
of my time studying
what i recommend doing is speeding up
the theory lectures to 1.25
1.5 speed but really taking your time
when it comes to doing the hands-on
exercises
so that you can consolidate your
knowledge so i definitely prefer
watching videos over reading notes and
documentation mainly because i find it
to be more engaging and easier to absorb
but there are many ebooks and aws white
papers out there that are really great
resources and i've linked everything
into the description below
finally what i did was i searched online
and found a bunch of practice questions
and went through as many of them as i
could before the exam
this was a really effective way to
identify gaps in my knowledge
and some of the practice exam websites
provided really good explanations on why
the answer was correct or incorrect
before making this video i revisited
these websites and found the ones that
really reflected the real exam
so definitely check it out in the
description below
even though i didn't buy any practice
exams for the cloud practitioner
certification
if i was to go back in time i would have
bought this course by tutorials dojo
i used their practice questions to
prepare for my solutions architect
associate and developer associate
certifications
and it was definitely super helpful and
had very high quality explanations
my final piece of advice is to book your
exam ahead of time
sometimes when we have so many things
going on with our lives it can be really
hard to prioritize doing certifications
by booking your exam for next month even
if you haven't started preparing for it
forces you to feel a sense of urgency so
that you can remember to block out time
for your cloud learning journey
if you're watching this and have your
exam coming up best of luck and let me
know how you go
if you're considering whether or not to
get aws certified i highly recommend
looking into the aws certification
website
and browsing through the different
certifications to see which one is best
for you
thanks so much for watching please give
this video a like if you found it
helpful
and subscribe for more videos like this
where i share tips on how to pass
different aws certification exams